video games have always been considered
a source of entertainment for adults and
children alike with an emphasis on fun
and challenge that builds hand-eye
coordination problem-solving skills an
extreme apathy towards the mental image
of a frosty ninja man ripping out an
electric rice farmers spine well that
last part wasn't always the case but
Edie Boone and company at Midway changed
the world as we know it with a little
series called misspelled combat and if
you haven't heard of this series by now
get ready to see some cool disclaimer
for the sensitive with the new Mortal
Kombat 11 coming out this year I came
out but feel nostalgic for one of my
favorite game series from my childhood I
still cherish the memories of watching
my parents play through Mortal Kombat
trilogy on ps1 and then doing an entire
co-op run of Shaolin monks with my mom
and dad taking turns as Kung Lao aside
from the comic book based stuff Mortal
Kombat is a franchise that has a special
place in my heart and I figured it was
time to write my big love letter to it
using the blood of my enemies so let's
review every Mortal Kombat game and even
some of the weird side stuff that
resulted from the series being so damn
popular maybe along the way we'll learn
some new stuff about the franchise and
figure out which was the best
ultraviolence simulator in the series
now bear in mind for the rest of this
series of videos I'm not some badass
fighting games expert who goes to Evo
tournaments and has a fancy $300
joystick I don't play every fighting
game out there and know all the
technical terms like juggles frame
advantage footsies frame data tech heads
and meter burning well actually I guess
I know all those terms but that's it
because I watched a lot of super best
friends play videos rest in pieces I
bought suit you took me so much useless
trivia so I'll do my best to not suck at
these games and make all the experts out
there cringe but I can already tell
there's going to be common - god save
you're such a noob you need to learn how
to block I can't believe you tried to
use that attack when it had a three
frame activation time it's your own
fault for leaving yourself open it hits
your pansy eye but you're not even a
real Mortal Kombat fan because you can't
get 43 consecutive flawless victories
with [__] mocap I don't exactly have
an arcade cabinet
available so our best option will be to
check out the 2011 re-release of the
original trilogy also spelled with a k
for some reason why is everything
spelled without it looks cooler
this goddamn keyboard style is an
abomination oh my god so let's load up
m'kay one hop to it if something so
cheesy and lovable about this first game
and hadn't really come into the tone and
style we associate these games with yet
but the goal was just to make a bad boy
version a street fighter with some blood
and violence it just felt like a big
amage two old kung fu movies from the
80s the premise is that fighters from
all over the multiverse go to this
tournament every generation to represent
their home realms in a battle to stop
this evil wizard Shang Tsung zum-zum son
whatever from taking over earth for his
Emperor boss we don't see yet but
whatever reason the bad guy team has to
win ten consecutive tournaments in order
to take over earth which feels a little
unfair to me like these tournaments
happen every 15 years why do you make
them wait so long I guess I admire their
patience these guys are magic and having
definite life spans and they seem to
love fighting so they're cool dat
whatevs
right off the bat I have to just say how
much I like this character roster
everyone is so unique and special in
their own way
these characters have their own little
recognizable quirks and traits that make
them memorable they all have really
unique moves and a personality that you
can see just from the way they fight or
do their victory pose even between Sub
Zero and scorpion who are palette swaps
at the same costume you can see a lot of
individuality I like how he knows robot
eye switches sides and who doesn't love
some good Liu Kang Kombat grunts
scorpions iconic
never gets old this game is really
progressive they let this Special Forces
officer break gender norms by wearing
yoga pants instead of a more traditional
urban combat uniform I can definitely
see why these characters are so iconic
and became mainstays of the series call
me basic but scorpions always been my
favorite of the bunch
Liu Kang is alright I guess but you know
what I'll talk about him another time
let's not ruin this apparently this game
was originally supposed to be about
jean-claude van Damme
but they couldn't get the rights to use
him so Johnny Cage is more or less a
parody of him and all this is kind of
funny in retrospect because Van Damme
later played guile in the Street Fighter
movie and turned down the role to play
Cage in the Mortal Kombat movie then
they did a street fighter the movie the
game where they ripped off Mortal Kombat
and used digitized actors from the movie
including jean-claude Van Der Beek is
any of this information useful is it
interesting kind of not exactly good at
older games I'd say that if a game is
older than the ps1 era I probably have
no hope of being it but this game is
surprisingly accessible granted I lost a
ton of times during the combat ladder
but eventually I can beat it after
enough tries for each fight long gone
are the days of shoving in your parents
hard earned quarters with every death
and spending about $30 trying to beat
the damn game the AI is pretty good at
reacting your moves and keeping you on
your toes for the majority of the game
it feels pretty fair and I never
considered it cheap when I lost except
for Goro I appreciate how balanced the
game feels you can beat every character
with every other character and every
character feels kind of fun to use in
their own right well know how infamous
this series is for its violence but I
really feel like this one's pretty tame
compared to the sequels
the fatality is scorpion is a little
annoying because the combo requires you
to hit up what happens when you hit up
you jump so a lot of the times you just
block and then hop like an idiot while
your enemy wobbles around waiting for
you to get your [__] together then he
just gets bored and lies down to make
you feel bad while Shang Tsung's sits in
this chair and laughs at your inferior
manhood but eventually I got it and boy
does it feel good to tear off your own
face and overcook a famous Hollywood
actor to let off some pent-up rage about
the current political
scorpions a civil rights activist you
see and know a lot of this sounds really
basic and simple but that's what this
game is it's baby's first fighting game
it's not like some of the newer ones
where you have 20 special moves per
character and roster of 45 characters
it's not about all that flash or XS it's
just about two eccentric guys with
shockingly elaborate backstories kicking
the crap out of each other with
charmingly basic graphics and
backgrounds I have you now Gargan oh
sorry I got a tip that scorpion was here
yes or someone else god I sure came a
long way and I'm low on web do you got
any cat fare man
after you smash your way through the
somewhat limited fighting roster and the
two versus one or endurance rounds you
get to goro the second-to-last boss
character he's apparently a half human
half dragon badass that fights for the
opposing team of Outworld whom I have
dubbed the Audi of boys they kind of
hype him up in this demo thingy at the
main menu plus you can hear him stomping
around in the fight directly before this
they want you to be afraid of this guy
and for good reason he is cheap he has a
lot of unblockable grabs you can knock
out like 30% of your health in one hit
he can cancel out some of your special
moves with his own can you imagine how
unfun and irritating the game would be
if every character fought like this
that'll be important for later but even
with this somewhat cheap AI he's still
not impossible to beat if you spam a lot
of jump kicks and special moves to make
sure to vary up which attack you use
because he'll get wise to it and start
blocking if you do the same thing too
frequently sorry sorry that's really
awkward I appreciate it though hey by
any chance you know a guy named Frank
Castle you kinda remind me of him you
got that same far-off look in your lack
of pupils his whole family was killed
it's a real tragedy come bet you're glad
you can't relate to that one huh
oh dude actually remind you another guy
after you curb stomp Ben Tennyson over
here Shang last name decides to stop
being a background element and take
matters into his own withered hands he's
not too hard of a fight himself it's
just like a big pop quiz to remember
which strategies work against which
characters if you've made it up to this
point you know pretty much every move
he'll try by shape-shifting into the
other guys so you can take him and thus
you kick his ass and get a special
ending for whichever character you're
playing as I love this game it's so
simple it's so elegant it's violent
weird and has a bit of a sense of humor
I also adore the amount of thought
behind the backgrounds for every
character in the lore of this world
I didn't definitely see why a movie or
TV producer would take a look at this
and think it has potential it is one of
my dreams to have an arcade cabinet of
this in my house whoa never mind I can't
afford that
after mk1 came out and lift the gaming
world on fire and then pulled its guts
out with a rusty hook every game
suddenly had to have gore and violence
after a decade of being perceived as
mostly harmless definitely aimed for
kids video games became something more
mature and frightening which got
concerned parents in the media panicking
that the nation's youth would become a
horde of bloodthirsty remorseless
killing machines a cold-blooded murder
is making Mortal Kombat the most popular
video game in history
kids relished their victory and their
bloody choice should they pull out their
opponents heart or simply rip his head
off just to see a spinal cord dangle at
a pool of blood how do you feel about
cutting it
that generation of kids is now my
generations parents and from what I can
tell they're just more jaded and
depressed they don't seem all that
violent to me regardless the new
wildfire of outrage led to the creation
of the ESRB haymakers are also talking
about a new rating system similar to the
movies classify games and keep the more
violent ones away from younger children
it also led to a lot of court cases
congressional hearings heavily censored
ports on home consoles and marketing
material and the best parts didn't
finish sequels
next up in the trilogy is mk2
which picks right up where the last one
left off Shang Shang Pootie Tang is now
in trouble with Shao Kahn the CEO evil
incorporated LLC for fumbling the ball
right at the finish line with the Mortal
Kombat win streak which means the gang
got away to another ten generations
before they can start building that
beachfront summer home on earth atop the
endless mounds of human corpses so he
rounds up some more bad guys plus some
returning faces from the first game try
one more time with an all-or-nothing
second tournament if the human race wins
this one Shao Kahn [__] off backed out
world to polish a skull helmet
collection he wins he gets to be
president of Earth the roster is bigger
there are more combos and fatalities and
the gore is even sillier than before it
really upped their game this time they
even added a new finisher where you can
befriend your opponent as a middle
finger at all the censorship and outrage
nice to see they added reptile who is a
secret character in the first game that
could only be fought via an incredibly
stupid amount of side tasks that was way
too demanding Kung Lao was mentioned in
some throw away back storyline from the
first game and I get the impression that
he died like 80 years ago but he's here
so I guess this is like his descendant
or something
Johnny Cage finally has pants sub-zero
was technically killed in the first game
by scorpion so now we've got his younger
brother who has similar fashion taste
I think the costumes really improved
this time around everyone looks way
cooler even Shane got some kind of youth
powerup and is a playable character now
alright let's grab my boy scorpion and
hop to it
Wow someone seems a little harder that's
to be expected it's a sequel will
soldier on alright I beat him we got
this first steps the hardest right okay
god come on
Jesus really oh [__] come on ah don't
you dare
[Applause]
yeah son of a [__] expletive yes games
hard so first I thought I just need to
up my dosage of get good pills but it
turns out this game is sort of infamous
for being the one that's way too [__]
hard according to the Internet assume
message boards of people talking about
how to damn near impossible to get a hit
on the AI opponents unless they allow
you to I've seen entire videos
explaining the amount of things that the
AI can do that the player can't like
chaining certain two moves together
activating certain moves at whatever
distance it feels like instead of the
one that it says in the move list doing
animations faster than the player
character can and the AI difficulties
scaling up to the hardest as you
progress even if you put it it the
easiest to start after a couple of
rounds of getting my ass handed to me I
said it the very easy mode and all it
did was give me a slight handicap for
the first three guys on the challenge
ladder and then after that it goes right
back that being impossible the reason
for this is because the game can read
your inputs which means it knows exactly
what buttons you're hitting right as you
hit them and in response it can block or
counter-attack right away which means if
I do an uppercut the enemy knows I'm
going to do it before the animation can
show scorpion even finish crouching
normally the AI in games would react the
animation of your character so if you do
this spear move the guy would normally
block after you've started throwing it
you know like how a real person would
react not in this game the other guy
knows you're throwing the spear before
you even finish reaching in your pocket
to grab it because it looked at your
button inputs [__] dude even the
hitboxes suck most of the time when I do
a high punch or low punch it just passes
a millimeter away from their face so I'm
just swinging like an idiot for a few
seconds and can't make any contact you
have to be practically standing on top
of your opponent to even punch them the
game is cheating and this was just like
acceptable at the time lol games were
just harder back in my day you young
whippersnappers are just lame
the AI allows you a small fighting
chance to get in a few straight hits
lets you do just enough damage to get
cocky and think you're only losing due
to a lack of skill it tricks you into
thinking you have a shot but it really
just comes down to dumb luck to beat
some of these fights and you know why to
manipulate you into spending more money
on it yeah if the AI beats the absolute
crap out of you but lets you manage to
do a small amount of damage it fools you
into wanting to put one more quarter in
and give it one more try
but maybe this time you get it in about
three good hits and you feel like you're
learning so one more one more try then
that starts to add up until eventually
you've wasted fifty dollars just to beat
the first six fights god help your
wallet and your wrists and your sanity
if you ever get to Shao Kahn I've seen
people arguing that it's not that bad
and you just have to do a very specific
sequence of combos to confuse the AI and
then hit the opponent while they're
glitched out and jumping and then spam
that set of moves until the match is
over
bull [__] that's not fun that's not
based on skill that's just trying to out
cheat the cheating
I shouldn't have to bug out the AI and
do the same repetitive four-step
solution to win every fight I can't
believe someone thinks that choosing the
AI in order to win every single fight is
a good game design and be fun instead of
just repetitive I like the graphics the
music the stages fatalities and story in
this game but the most basic part of it
the gameplay is just broken that being
said it's still fun to play versus with
a friend I suppose they can't read your
button inputs and [__] on you constantly
I guess that's not really a plus that's
just how any normal video game would
work well since I can't beat this to
save my life let's go look it up on
YouTube alright lots of stuff to skip
through and then you get to Goro part 2
basically the same character design but
with tiger stripes because why not
Quintero has slightly different moves
but it's not much to differentiate him
from Goro
see even the guy in this playthrough is
just backing Kintaro into a corner and
spamming the same kick over and over
to win because that's really all you can
do after that he cheese's shao kahn's AI
by spamming the upper cut and then
Skeletor is more flamboyant brother
explodes you get a little back story on
scorpion and learned that he's sorry for
massacre izing sub-zero in the first
game because he has a little brother
who's a nice guy in this one so they
become best buds and love is all you
need your ending may vary depending on
what character you bug the AI with to
get this point and basically the Canon
ending of all three games is that Liu
Kang is the one who wins but scorpions
my favorite we're doing that instead
also the comments on this video
speculate that the person had to hack
the game in order to beat it so whoops
man if I had a physical copy of this and
it wasn't in a package with two way
better games it would be getting the one
more day treatment right now something
fierce
Mortal Kombat 3 no ninjas no mercy Shao
Kahn survived this somehow and has
returned angrier than ever that he can't
invade earth so instead of doing Mortal
Kombat again he just invades earth
because mk2 set a dangerous precedent
that cheating is totally fine for all
parties involved you're ruining the
youth of Outworld with this [__] II D so
much for being an example for the kids
con I thought you were an honorable
multi-dimensional tyrant with a skull
face I know who I'm not voting for next
time this time we're not on spooky
fistfight Island or being teleported out
world the maps are all right here in
nondescript city USA where Kahn and his
invading forces of evil have chosen to
drill for our oil or whatever alright
let's take a look at the roster of MK 3
well the first version of MK 3 strasser
sucks and some of the best characters
aren't even here how the hell do you not
have scorpion katana Raiden Molina and
Johnny Cage were also all left out for
some reason they won't specify publicly
I did some research and it says that a
lot of the actors from the first two
games wanted more royalties from their
performances being used in the console
ports of am game 1 & 2 which they didn't
get so they bailed and had to be read
so Sonia Liu Kang and liuxiang are all
different Midway wanted less ninjas to
appear in this game for some reason so
noob saibot is a recolored version of
Kano now scorpions just flat-out missing
in action and sub-zero Junior has
renounced his ninja ways and left his
clan or something meanwhile all
remaining ninjas from sub-zero clan were
kidnapped and forcibly turned into rad
looking cyborgs he got cool new guys in
the roster like a cop I can't tell if
this is an offensive stereotype another
less cool looking cyborg katanas elderly
mother and girls second cousin who
doesn't get invited to parties yeah I
can see why they released an updated
version because damn so Ultimate Mortal
Kombat 3 brings back scorpion katana
Jade reptile and even throws in a free
extra cyborg ninja named smoke he is my
other favorite character in the series I
don't know why you think I'd be more
attracted to the image of the red and
black cyborg ninja when I was a kid but
nope
smoke was always the one that I thought
was the coolest when watching my mom and
pop play this game in the living room of
our condo circa 2001 according to the
lore smoke is sub-zero's buddy who is
cyber ties between games man the robots
really are taking all the good jobs you
can't be a ninja in this economy without
worrying about some otamatone putting
you out on the street with a dumb vest
and a cartoonishly big eye scar smoke
was a secret character in mk2 but he
didn't have any special moves just a
color swap of scorpion ironically in
this game he still has scorpion spear
attack albeit a robot version see this
one's actually playable it's not a
complete cakewalk and I lose a few
rounds here and there but I feel like I
have a genuine shot at getting to the
final boss here probably has something
to do with me picking novice mode like a
counter game is pretty much your
standard fare but now you get a sprint
button in an actual combo not a
figurative combo like this time if you
hammer a sequence of buttons it makes
for a special animation that looks real
rad much like mk2 you can grab and throw
enemies plus you can do stage
transitions uppercut someone hard enough
and they'll go flying through the
ceiling into a different arena that's
really damn satisfying can't perform a
fatality because I suck and I can't
figure out where to properly stand on
the stage I'll look The Bodyguard
sub-boss is fine
different in this game instead of a
scary demon man with four arms now it's
a scary demon man with four legs did I
mention I love how creative this series
is now I've made it to Shao Kahn
unrelated to the show Khan and the
Shaolin and he's a mean bastard hue
montage of me getting my ass kicked and
after about 30 minutes of struggling one
flawless victory somehow in the middle
and a lot of almost the unthinkable
happens
I just keep landing hits left and right
you can't touch me everything's going
amazing
and then the game freezes and I've lost
all my progress
oh look what's that over there hey look
at that how nice as an added bonus to
tie up the trilogy I'll review Mk
trilogy but okay which in my opinion is
the best version of MK 3 maybe in this
port I can beat Shao Kahn uh nope he's
even worse this time he'll even seems to
do extra moves that I don't remember
like this grab attack that happened so
fast I can't react to it I also have a
way harder time remembering to block
because it's a different button on this
version and I'm all discombobulated also
his energy streaks from when he moves
super fast or a different color
headcanon Shao Kahn is Johnny Cage from
an alternate timeline speaking of let's
run down the list of cool features in
this port you can play as every
character in the series up to that point
right from the start
even the boss characters like Goro
Kintaro and motaro every bad guy has to
have row at the end of their name you'll
also play as a nerf version of Shao Kahn
you got new Johnny Cage as a playable
character again even though he's
canonically dead Baraka Molina katana
Jade all the ninja characters in the
series so far here including rain which
is a prince reference and erm ACK which
is an easter egg based on a glitch in
the previous games all the characters
costumes are red and real-life but
changed to blue or yellow and post there
was a glitch called error macro with the
second game that made the ninja
characters coloring disappear and revert
back to the standard red so now that's a
character you gotta love how the
original trilogy can come up with new
characters from so little noob saibot is
back to being a ninja sprite and weirdly
the only ninja who's like stealthy but
you find out in his ending that he's
actually the big brother sub-zero from
the first game so that's a neat lore now
him and scorpion or weirdo revenge
ghosts you also have a classic costume
for sub-zero since the unmasked one
looks kind of lame Raiden is back as a
playable character
apparently the actor playing him Carlos
cocina got in some trouble for doing
some work for a competitor game called
tattooist
asin's they didn't fire him but they
punished him by cutting out his
character from the first two versions of
mk3 and then a trilogy having Raiden
sprites just recycled from mk2 or any
extra moves being filmed with a
different actor in the costume there's
actually a lot of stuff in here recycled
from NK 1 & 2 like a few fighting stages
from those games and even alternate
versions of some characters you can play
as Jax with arms and Kung Lao with a
shirt oh my god this fatality is ironic
they have all their old moves and
fatalities from MK 2 plus you can play
as Kano and Raiden from MK 1 it's got a
neat pinning the old new versions of
these characters together and seeing
what's changed with the graphics and
fighting styles this port also has the
added feature of cheats to make things a
little easier for you like regenerating
health instant super meter and a cheat
that makes all the fatalities take one
button press well finally I can see what
these look like goddamn smoke is
overpowered I have to say with all the
work and the extra junk that went into
this port I got a call up the definitive
way to play MK 3 it gives you your
money's worth with characters stages and
the sheer amount of fatalities and
endings and this cute little dance Cyrax
does there you go 5 games for the price
of 3 they're jumping either way I got
all classic gold mage Mortal Kombat out
of the way next up is the Wonder Years
and I call it that because I wonder what
the hell everyone was thinking with the
unquestionable success of this series
adaptations and side shenanigans were
bound to happen so we've gotten to the
era of Mortal Kombat growing pains
just a quick reminder before you go that
I post my videos a day early on patreon
and give exclusive behind-the-scenes
content and patron exclusive videos
please consider becoming a patron it
really helps me out if you want a more
short-term way to support the channel
you can check out my merch and the links
in the description we have t-shirts
phone cases posters mugs pillows baby
onesies and so much more
see you next time
[Music]